ja das kam gerade ganz klar über jetzt
bei dieser pressekonferenz 12 seiten
über zwölf seiten spricht deutschland
hier liegen sie diese jürgen
papier der ampel jahner dass sie gerade
auch veröffentlicht haben und da steckt
schon allerhand drin das ist sozusagen
ihre allererste teilweise um konkrete
teilweise aber auch schon etwas konkrete
idee für ihre vier jahre regierungszeit
für die zukunft deutschlands bei uns im
studio bildpolitik chef jan schäfer das
papier hier da steckt einiges drin hab
ich schon gesagt wir wollen über die
inhalte sprechen aber erstmal über die
zentrale botschaft offenbar funktioniert
mit der ampel zumindest noch also wir
haben gerade die pressekonferenz gesehen
ganz genau die spitzen der drei parteien
spd grüne und fdp empfehlen ihren
gremien jetzt darüber abzustimmen und
darüber positiv abzustimmen über diese
zwölf seiten um dann in
koalitionsverhandlungen in der nächsten
woche einsteigen zu können und jetzt
schauen wir aber ganz genau rein jetzt
haben wir inhaltlich rein in diese zwölf
seiten das will die abend will k s eben
gerade gesagt man hat sich auf vieles
schon festgelegt beispielsweise der
mindestlohn der steigt auf 12 euro
urlaubs- hatte das bereits im wahlkampf
die ganze zeit als sein eines seiner
großen ziele erklärt konnte sich ja noch
mal hier auch durchsetzen er konnte sich
durchsetzten ganz genauso wie auch die
grünen beide parteien haben immer davon
gesprochen den mindestlohn auf 12 euro
am liebsten in einem schritt anzuheben
wir sind derzeit bei 9 eur 60 und genau
das passiert jetzt auch und es heißt in
diesem papier bereits im ersten jahr das
heißt wir können davon ausgehen
2022 wird der mindestlohn waren auch
immer möglicherweise nicht zum ersten
ersten aber innerhalb der ersten zwölf
monate dann angehoben auf 12 euro das
ist ein gewaltiger schritt das sind
deutlich über 20% lohnaufschlag das ist
schon ziemlich viel und gern
wahlversprechen eben von der spd von
olaf scholz das heißt hier schon einmal
jack haken dran 12 euro mindestlohn
kommen und die fdp trägt das mit das hat
christian lindner gerade gesagt das muss
die fdp also verschmerzen nochmal blick
drauf auf diese tafel denn das sind die
punkte auf die sich die amerikaner bis
hierher geeinigt haben in ihren
sondierungsgesprächen punkt nummer zwei
jahren bürgergeld starts hartz4 was kann
ich mir darunter vorstellen außer dass
es nett klingt genau ausklinken netter
und das wird sich auch sicherlich nicht
ganz so schnell umsetzen lassen das ist
eine idee der fdp das sogenannte
liberale bürgergeld da geht es darum
dass man aus den hartz 4 empfängern
keine antragsteller im herkömmlichen
sinne wir machen möchte sondern sie eher
animieren möchte einen job aufzunehmen
und dass man beispielsweise bei dem die
liberalen bürgergeld die chance bekommt
wenn man nebenbei sich etwas dazu
verdient auch mehr von diesem extra
lohnen den mann hat behalten zu können
also weniger an den staat abgeben muss
und die idee ist zu sagen menschen im
noch eine arbeit auf es hilft hier und
da so aus hartz 4 oder aus der stütze
heraus zu wachsen wieder in ein normales
job verhältnis lässt uns weiter in
dieses papier hineinblicken dass man
kann es sagen ja schon etwas über die
zukunft unseres landes verrät die punkte
bei denen man sich jetzt schon einig ist
deutschland soll schneller und
effektiver werden keine rentenkürzungen
auch das ist gebe aber noch einmal
zurück denn klima ganz großes thema auch
hier hatte man streit befürchtet wie
wird das bezahlt wie kann man die ziele
der grünen erreichen ist es völlig klar
tempolimit davon muss man sich
verabschieden das hat robert habeck jan
ja auch im gerade in der pressekonferenz
gesagt da konnten wir uns nicht
durchsetzen das ist richtig aber die
grünen sind sonst was den punkt angeht
und das was man bisher in diesem
sondierungs papier lesen kann eigentlich
sehr gut weggekommen haben sich sehr
stark durchsetzen können es soll unter
anderem eine solardach pflicht geben bei
neubauten achtung nicht für privathäuser
aber zumindest für gewerbliche häuser
also für industrieunternehmen oder
generell unternehmen das zweite ganz
wichtig ist wird darauf hingearbeitet
dass der kohleausstieg ja beschlossen
vor zwei jahren 20 38 sollen die letzten
kohlekraftwerke vom netz gehen um bis zu
acht jahre vorgezogen wird also auf das
jahr
2030 das heißt dieser mühsame
kohlekompromiss der wird noch mal
aufgeschnürt noch mal aufgemacht genau
das datum ist nicht fix 2030 das heißt
bestenfalls auf 20 30 vorziehen das
würde bedeuten dass wir eigentlich in
neun jahren dann schon komplett aus der
kohle aussteigen das halte ich für einen
wirklich harten harten und großen
brocken wissen dass die kohle im ersten
halbjahr dieses jahres 27 prozent zum
gesamten strom mit beigetragen hat also
mehr als ein viertel und dieses mehr als
ein viertel das will man also innerhalb
der nächsten neun jahre dann komplett
ersetzen das ist eine sehr sehr sehr
große herausforderung ich bin nicht
sicher und würde eher sagen das klappt
nicht und solarzellen pflicht du hast es
gesagt für alle gewerblichen neubauten
heißt auf jedem supermarkt
beispielsweise müssen künftig
solarzellen seien die eben die
sonnenenergie aufnehmen und umwandeln
wir schauen weiter rein in die
wichtigsten punkte dieser zwölf seiten
über die ab heute deutschland spricht
und deutschland diskutiert wir haben
gesprochen über klimaschutz und sprechen
natürlich auch über die andere kohle
über steuererhöhungen ja oder nein in
dem papier steht drin ganz klar nein die
kommen nicht jan ja da konnte sich die
fdp zumindest teilweise durchsetzen die
ja im wahlkampf gesagt hat keine
steuererhöhungen und auch keine neuen
steuern beides konnte sie durchsetzen zb
gegen den wunsch der spd aber auch der
grünen für eine neue vermögenssteuer
gekämpft haben da heißt es ganz klar es
gibt keine neuen steuern und keine
steuererhöhungen aber das wollte die fdp
auch und da musste sie die waffen
strecken
sie wollte den solidaritätszuschlag
abschaffen komplett für alle das im wird
jetzt nicht passieren in klammern man
hofft darauf dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht im nächsten
jahr den soli sowieso kippen wird aber
es ist nicht mehr teil des sondierungs
papiers und wird damit auch nicht teil
des koalitionsvertrages werden olaf
scholz sagte er in der pressekonferenz
ist wird das größte industrielle
modernisierungsprojekte deutschland
wahrscheinlich seit über 100 jahren
durchgeführt hat grund genug noch einmal
detailliert in diese zwölf seiten
reinzuschauen zu schauen was die ampel
vor halb zwölf seiten man konnte sich
auf viele themen einigen man musste
einige kompromisse eingehen die wir hier
bereits erläutert haben was uns weiter
detailliert in dieses papier schauen
volle kraft auf digitalisierung heißt es
unter anderem darin auch weitere themen
weitere punkte wurden abgehakt am anfang
des papiers wurde ganz klar gesagt
natürlich konnten wir nicht alle punkte
beschreiben auch auf der pressekonferenz
wurde noch einmal deutlich gemacht ist
will gibt weitere punkt es gibt weiter
auch noch stoff für die rente die rente
zum beispiel auf die müssen mal gucken
hier steht ja darauf auf der tafel jetzt
geht es ein bisschen schneller aber
steht drin keine rentenkürzung dass die
positive nachricht vor allem in der spd
war dieses thema ja ganz wichtig die
rentenkürzung standen allerdings auch
gar nicht an das bisher noch gar nicht
groß in der diskussion aber spannend
wird's wenn wir über die gesetzliche
rente sprechen ja da gibt es das war der
fdp besonders wichtig eine ganz
besondere neuerung richtig rente ist ein
entscheidender faktor weil er ein großer
kostenfaktor ist im bundeshaushalt über
100 milliarden also über 100 milliarden
fließen mittlerweile jedes jahr aus dem
bundeshaushalt in die rentenkasse und es
gibt zwei punkte die entscheidend dabei
sind es soll diese sogenannte haltelinie
also das rentenniveau soll auch nicht
weiter sinken das wollten grüne und spd
bei 48 prozent festschreiben das bleibt
so und ganz wichtig es soll in den
nächsten vier jahren nicht über ein
späteres renteneintrittsalter
debattiert werden das heißt die rente
mit 67 bleibt die wird nicht zur rente
mit 68 oder 976 die bleibt auch das
wichtig bedeutet aber dass die rente
natürlich weiterhin extremer
kostenfaktor ist noch teurer werden wird
ein punkt konnte sich die fdp
durchsetzen und zwar beim thema
finanzierung es wird künftig die rente
nicht nur aus den beiträgen der
arbeitnehmer bezahlt werden und aus dem
steuersäckel sondern es wird sowas geben
wie einen extra rentenkonto einen
kapitalstock da soll zunächst erstmal
zehn milliarden euro einfließen das ist
jetzt nicht sehr viel wenn man überlegt
dass in die rentenzahlung pro jahr bei
über 300 milliarden liegen aber ganz
klar ist da ist ein erster punkt ein
erster baustein dass man auch
beispielsweise von entwicklungen
aktienmärkten profitieren möchte und
nicht nur von dem was die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer aber
so der staat zahlt von unseren renten
ein beiträgen und für unsere künftigen
renten ein in einen fonds legt das geld
an in aktien beispielsweise das kann zu
einer dividende führen das kann aber
auch zu verlusten führen theoretisch
vollkommen richtig jetzt könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass so angelegt wird gibt
genug modelle dass man das eingezahlte
geld nicht verlieren kann aber muss sich
das vorstellen dass man wie in einen
privaten renten von dann eins das macht
der staat jetzt und er hofft dass dieses
dieser kleine betrag von 10 milliarden
immer stärker an wächst also dass man
künftig aus da auch daraus
rentenerhöhung beispielsweise
finanzieren das ist die idee die
dahinter steckt jetzt lasst uns auf die
jungen menschen blicken denn auch für
die stehen nachrichten in diesem papier
junger die vor allem auch die fdp
gewählt haben und die jetzt bei der
nächsten wahl deutlich früher wählen
sollen sie sollen wir künftig ab 16 und
zwar nicht nur auf kommunaler ebene das
ist ja bereits heute möglich sondern
eben auch auf bundesebene und auch für
die europawahl das ist das was im
sondierungs papier steht wir sehen
gerade den lanz naja
also erfährt ja gerade ab an der
berliner messe das ist heute das muss
man auch mal auf ihn persönlich noch mal
fokussieren das ist der nächste schritt
heute in seine kanzlerschaft also ein
historischer moment für ihn er hat das
gerade erledigt den nächsten haken
sozusagen dran gemacht an dem bau seiner
künftigen koalition wichtiger schritt in
richtung seiner kanzlerschaft aber
zurück zu diesem thema vor allen dingen
für alle jungen menschen auch
jugendliche in deutschland wichtig das
wahlalter soll gesenkt werden so hast du
es gerade gemacht gesagt jan auch für
bei der bundestagswahl nach bei der
bundestagswahl so steht es zumindest im
sondierungs papier jetzt drin die
bundestagswahlen sollen künftig oder
16-jährige sollen künftig die chance
haben bei der bundestagswahl auch mit zu
wählen dass es bisher erst ab 18 möglich
und es soll die gleiche möglichkeit auch
geben bei den europawahlen also für
jüngere menschen die noch nicht
erwachsen sind eher bieten sich hier
durchaus zweifel sind dann an der
willensbildung teilzuhaben eines
fragezeichen dran kann man das
durchsetzen als ampel wohl nein das
braucht auch die zustimmung von cdu csu
selbst wenn sie an der bundesregierung
nicht mehr beteiligt sind das braucht
eine zweidrittelmehrheit dann solche
änderungen am wahlrecht richtung richtig
genau das heißt dass wird dürfte schwer
werden aber unseren jungs papier ist ja
auch gemacht um mir jetzt in der eigenen
basis für zustimmung zu sorgen die
grünen müssen am sonntag bei einem
kleinen länderrat sich die zustimmung
und dass das grün sozusagen holen das ok
damit sie in koalitionsverhandlungen
einsteigen können die fdp wird es am
montag machen da soll der vorstand
zusammen mit der fraktion darüber
beraten und ebenfalls grünes licht geben
die spd will das mit ihren
vorstandsmitgliedern auch besprechen
also jetzt sind die parteimitglieder
gefragt bzw die delegierten um grünes
licht zu geben dass man in den nächsten
schritt gehen kann in die richtigen
harten koalitionsverhandlung zwölf
seiten zwölf wichtige seiten jan welche
punkte sind noch wichtig worauf konnte
man sich einigen und konntest du auch
jetzt eben anhand dieser pressekonferenz
auch schon punkte bemerken wo man sagen
könnte jetzt mit blick auf die
koalitionsverhandlungen auf die man sich
geeinigt hat da könnte es dann
vielleicht doch noch einmal knirschen
olaf scholz hat sich jetzt auch
optimistisch gezeigt und auch im papier
heißt es ja wir sind davon überzeugt
dass wir einen ambitionierten und
tragfähigen koalitionsvertrag schließen
können also dass das resumee der drei
parteien zu diesem papier ja ein
wichtiger punkt wo du gerade nämlich
danach fragt ist da geht es um das thema
wohnen da geht es um das thema bauen
zwar für olaf scholz extrem wichtig im
wahlkampf für die grünen auch und da hat
man sich geeinigt dass man pro jahr
400.000 neue wohnungen bauen möchte
hunderttausend davon staatlich auch
richtig gefördert um auch die mieten
unter diese situation auf dem mietmarkt
zu entspannen am ende und du fragst was
steht noch alles drin der wohnungs punkt
ist ein wichtiger etwas was nicht
drinsteht was er dabei extrem wichtig
ist ist die frage ja wie soll das am
ende alles finanziert werden ich glaube
das ist ein punkt über um den geht es
jetzt in den koalitionsverhandlungen das
liest sich jetzt alles sehr sehr schön
aber es ist der größte brocken die frage
wer bezahlt und deswegen der nächste
finanzminister der wirt den härtesten
job von allen ministern im kabinett
haben bei der derjenige sein wird der
die schuldenbremse dann auch wieder
einhalten muss und er muss das alles
finanzieren da wird es die großen
auseinandersetzung der nächsten wochen
geben um die frage was können wir euch
durchsetzen was können wir schnell
durchsetzen und was kann man vielleicht
doch gar nicht finanzieren und wer den
job kriegen sollte auch darüber wurde
noch nicht gesprochen das war gerade
interessanter moment auch die nachfrage
wurde gestellt und das machte dann
christian lindner kurz ganz verlegen
also
personalfragen
bisher noch nicht besprochen ist noch zu
früh dafür danke bildpolitik stefan
schäfer
[Musik]